You guys!
You've probably heard about the impossible
drive or the Em Drive, we literally just did
a video about it.
But there's already an update!
Hey spaced-out DNews fans, Trace here for
a DNews update.
This past weekend, we posted this video about
the EmDrive -- a resonant cavity thruster
that should allegedly move through space without
expelling matter to push against, potentially
violating a basic law of Newtonian Physics! It's a great video.
What timing we had though!
Because, several hours before we put the video
up, NASA's paper on the so-called 'impossible
drive' hit the hot sheets of the American
Institute of Aeronautics and Astronautics’
Journal of Propulsion and Power! One of my favorites.
One of my favorites. NASA's Eagleworks Laboratories
in Houston assayed the thrust from a 'Q-Thruster'.
Q-Thrusters are quantum vacuum plasma thrusters:
according to NASA theories, Q-thrusters push
off quantum particles to generate movement...
Like a propeller for the quantum ocean of
space.
This  family of thrusters includes the EmDrive,
but also other designs like the Cannae and
Mach-Lorentz drives.
So, the Q-thruster NASA tested produced approximately
1.2 millinewtons per kilowatt.
That's pretty significant.
It's "two orders of magnitude" more other
out-there techs like light sails (which use
the power of the solar wind or lasers), but
less than the potential of ion-thrusters that
shoot individual charged particles; and technically
ion thrusters aren't propellant free anyway.
You can see videos on all of these things here on DNews.
To test this, they put their Q-Thruster on
a low-thrust torsion pendulum, basically its an
uber-balanced rotational arm to measure micronewton
thrust.
The pendulum was balanced perfectly to give
the thruster experiment the illusion of zero-gravity
conditions, and then the whole setup was placed
inside a vacuum chamber to eliminate any movement
of air.
They even dampened any quote "harmonic" or
"oscillatory" motions, as well as vibration.
And they registered 1.2 millinewtons per kilowatt.
They then ran a bunch of experiments to make
sure the thrust they measured wasn't simply
expansion due to heat, electricity running
through the system, or anything else they
could think of… they even called it out
in the paper: saying errors could be from radio frequencies
bouncing off the inside of the vacuum chamber,
magnetic interaction from the power cables,
heating of the pendulum itself, unaccounted-for
vibrations, electrostatic interaction, outgassing,
even stray photons were accounted for!
And they still registered 1.2 millinewtons
per kilowatt!
But before you celebrate in the streets, a
published paper does not mean the 'impossible
drive' is perfect, or even that it works.
Mostly, what the publishing of a paper indicates
is, an experiment was reviewed by the researchers'
peers and found to be valid, meaning no obvious
experimental eff-ups.
The researchers even admitted they still need
to account for the heating of the components,
but holy crap.
This thing could work!
True propellantless propulsion could mean
we could get to the moon in hours, to Mars
in days!
But before you get excited scientists aren't
yet convinced and until they rule out all
the errors they can think of, they're going
to keep researching.
So watch this space.
If you are thoroughly confused by this whole
thing and want to know WTF is this emDrive
trace is on about?
Find out in this video!
And subscribe.
And like.
And share.
And tell us what planet you'd go to if you
could in the comments!
And thanks for watching.